in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
and Stephanie are with us welcome guys
how are you welcome good to have you or
do you guys live Atlanta Georgia fine
okay well welcome to Nashville so you're
here to do a debt free scream yes
and how much have you paid off just at a
hundred and sixty thousand Wow and how
long did that take 14 months great love
it Wow very fast making what kind of
money just over one hundred two hundred
and ten excellent what do you two do for
a living so we do we both have corporate
jobs I'm in finance I work for if I
serve but we also do financial coaching
okay excellent very good and he's an IT
or sales okay good
and this still doesn't add up though
hardly I mean you must have sold
something did you sell something we
actually got some stocks from my company
that invested during the time how much
how much was that forty thousand forty
okay all right that helps yeah
I couldn't I can breathe now that's
right there's a math the math after
taxes was pretty tight okay rice and
bean support tonight you guys have
really been intense though just the same
yeah we really kind of have I mean like
over the top a crazy intense yeah I
pitched a few temper tantrums did you
over what was the source of that well so
you have I guess when we saved up our
emergency fund and then we know how much
we're making when you combine incomes
and obviously before we were single and
it wasn't as much and so when you
combine both and then you look at the
money that you're making and you want to
buy something or you want to go do
something and it's kind of like why not
and luckily I had my accountability
partner on my side and basically he just
kind of talked me off the ledge every
single time
it was like well what is our goal what's
our plan and so okay so how long have
you two been married right around 14
months oh okay that's how this starts
okay yeah okay so we before we get
married we sit down we go okay come back
from the honeymoon it's hardcore so
actually our honeymoon was during one of
your trainings we got married on a
Sunday it's okay we still took time we
got married on a Sunday and then on
Monday we came to your master series
financial coach training Wow and spent
the whole week here
that's okay we're still married that's
just a month later okay okay the real
honeymoon okay good I feel better so but
really I mean you're making all this
money is what you're saying you're
adding it up you're going with make over
200 grand and I can't buy beans
basically I can buy rice but not beans I
mean really I mean it's so it was hard
yeah even for a financial coach yes and
and I guess that was the biggest thing
too was we wanted after we went through
the coaching series we were we wanted to
teach we wanted to walk in the walk that
we talked and so we wanted to make sure
that when we met with our clients that
we could empathize and sympathize with
them and understand what they're going
through so we had to do it yeah I'm just
I'm guessing Chris now if Stephanie's
sitting across from some lady who's
saying she wants to buy something I
would say Stephanie's pretty much
merciless now yeah I've been there done
that
stop your dadgum whining put on your
big-girl pants and get it done I mean
that you've been there you did it yeah I
mean this is very cool I love it he
actually asked me here he actually told
me that he was like are you done there
were there were definite moments that we
both were up on the ledge sure we it's
it's so crazy to think that we were on
track for paying off our mortgage and we
wanted to go buy a new house during that
process and then we just you know it was
one of those things where we're both on
the ledge we're both ready to go buy it
and we just had to really say who's
gonna walk off of us you know walk back
first almost legend bring someone else
with him I'm sorry so it was tough so
the hundred sixty thousand was your home
that was a big chunk of there's 124 bit
then we had two cars and a credit card
as well okay so you show you have a
house to spread for how old are you - 30
and 29 and you've been married 14 months
when you have paid for house and Atlanta
Georgia that's worth how much how does
it feel and it'd be 30 years old not
have a house payment even liberating
yeah it's just babies we kind of don't
even know what to do with ourselves but
at the same time we have to have a plan
we are focusing on contentment and just
making
sure that we give back and you follow
where the Lord wants us to go with it
it's at the point now where it's always
been laid on Stephanie's heart to be a
financial coach where she's wanted to do
this for years and now there's a real
like it's realistic like it could
actually happen at any point yeah I mean
you got the income and you you know you
don't have any in bills I mean it's just
it's incredible how much you'll be able
to do whatever you want to do whatever
it is whatever whether it's just simple
giving or whether it's setting yourself
up to be you know service thing like
that where you can give I mean there's
all kinds of ways this was going to work
out and that it's going to be so
stinking profitable in your lives I mean
your lives are gonna be changed forever
this is amazing
you guys are rock stars man this is this
is cool very very cool
so Stephanie you're coaching those
people out there that are listening what
are the secrets to getting out of that I
would definitely have to say for me
personally because I heard the girl
earlier she did it on her own for a
little while but for me it was an
accountability partner because I
struggled for maybe six years on my own
I'm just kind of getting on plan and
getting off the plan and then I met him
and it was really finding the
accountability whether or not you find a
husband or a spouse or a wife I think
it's finding accountability so a friend
a mother a parent a coach just somebody
to help you hold you accountable because
we're human we have once and needs and
desires as well so it's having someone
hold you accountable yeah it's a major
and it's the number one thing in
behavior modification is to have someone
to to you know to encourage you when
you're when you're down on the one hand
and on the other hand to just bust your
chops when you think you're on the ledge
you know and that kind of thing so Chris
what do you think the secrets are I was
definitely being determined dedicated
you know just to stay focused on what we
were trying to achieve and knowing that
the purpose wasn't for us it was for our
kids it was for our kids kids right or
even then it was for those that we
coached and those that you know we want
them to follow our lead and we just you
know we've been called to do this and
there's no question on that if the
leader in our heart
and we want to serve any way we can yeah
I mean if you come through master coach
series on your honeymoon you're pretty
much called that's pretty well you're
that's pretty well you're there I know
you're dialed in at that point
oh my gosh yeah I there's no way Shirin
Ramsey was going to that I would say
that wouldn't happen right there she
would have said you you you do need to
answer a different phone because you got
the wrong call oh you both wanted to do
it that's what I'm sorry that that helps
yeah I might have done it but not you no
never never never that's funny I love it
you guys are something special this is
very cool thirty years old a paid for
home a $200,000 income and pay off a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars and
14 months and that's how long they've
been married Chris and Stephanie from
Atlanta Georgia
counted down let's hear your debt free
scream alright three two one
well done you too that's pretty stinking
fun right there Wow excellent excellent
job very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim